look at that the low-lying clouds over
the snow-capped peaks of the spring
mountains just a really nice shot from
our Sunset Station camera and well not a
lot going on right now but things are
going to accelerate at least the winds
are as the day wears on it's 50 degrees
half century mark on the button out at
Harry Reid International with the
overcast skies and we are three degrees
warmer than we were at this time
yesterday with calm winds there's a 47
down at Henderson executive but most
stations are right around the 50 degree
Mark oh big low up over Vancouver Island
moving ashore and trailing frontal
system boy that has caused multiple
weather advisories around to the West in
the Pacific coast but for us we're
mainly concerned with wind advisories
from Lake Mead down to Southern Nevada
and also over the spring mountains which
is in effect until 10 o'clock tonight
those will be warm winds and we'll feel
them in the valley even though we're not
under an advisory you could see some
blowing dust and the mid 60's on the
Strip 64 over at the Lakes 68 downtown
Henderson Seven Hills looking at 67 and
highs today around to the region 67 in
Pahrump 52 way up in Caliente Amargosa
Valley in at 65. 66. we'll go for the
official high with Gusty afternoon winds
possible blowing dust and a possible
shower developing this afternoon into
the evening and overnight hours but I
don't think everybody will get them
they'll be scattered around hit or miss
the Gusty winds will continue after dark
but it'll be a mild evening with
temperatures bottoming out at 50 degrees
about where they are right now and we're
back in the 60s on Wednesday with the
morning showers and then cooling off a
bit as we head into the New Year's
weekend